yeah I would say that your career is
always going to be there m I had my son
at 36 there's never a right time if you
are an ambitious driven person you'll
somehow juggle it and then you'll ask
yourself in a few years after you've
done it God how did I do that family is
important for me so important when
you're going home you want to go home to
your family you want to go home to the
things that make you happy in life and
it's nice having a business and stuff
but if that's all you're working for the
hours the days the nights will pass and
before you know it you're 50 and you
haven't done certain things to kind of
like make sure that you've embedded your
family and things that you think were
worthwhile and you're for resentful